THAT.
PETER DOOCY, THANK YOU.
SANDRA.
>> Sandra: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE GOING TO BRING IN TEXAS
DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN HENRY
CUELLAR, HIS CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IS LOCATED ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, YOU ARE A HUGE
VOICE IN ALL OF THIS.  WHAT IS
YOUR MESSAGE TO THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS HOUR, KNOWING YOU AND YOUR
FELLOW REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT
COLLEAGUES HAVE PENNED A LETTER
TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO DO
SOMETHING.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO LISTEN
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THE
COMMUNITIES AT THE BORDER.
THE BORDER COMMUNITIES ARE
ASKING FOR HELP.
THE MEN AND WOMEN IN GREEN AND
IN BLUE ARE ASKING FOR HELP.
SO, WE HAVE TO CHANGE SOMETHING.
JUST ACTING IF EVERYTHING IS OK
OR THE BORDER IS SECURE, WHICH
IT'S NOT SECURE, WE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE GOT TO WITH MEXICO, TOUGHER
WITH MEXICO, WORK WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE GUATEMALA, SO WE
CAN STOP THEM FROM COMING IN.
AS LONG AS THEY FEEL THAT THE
BORDER IS OPEN, THIS IS NOT
GOING TO STOP.
>> Sandra: I MEAN, THERE ARE
SOME IN YOUR PARTY WHO WON'T
EVEN SAY THAT.
THEY WON'T EVEN SAY THE BORDERS
ARE OPEN, AND THEY ARE.
WE SEE PEOPLE POURING IN RECORD
NUMBERS OVER OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
EACH AND EVERY DAY.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THE WHITE
HOUSE IS NOT LISTENING?
>> THREE GROUPS OF PEOPLE YOU
NEED TO LISTEN TO.
IMMIGRATION ACTIVISTS, THAT'S
ONE, I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO LISTEN TO
THE MEN AND WOMEN IN GREEN AND
BLUE BUT ALSO GOT TO LISTEN
ESPECIALLY TO THE COMMUNITIES ON
THE BORDER.
I LIVE AT THE BORDER, I DON'T
JUST GO AND VISIT THERE, I
LISTEN.
THERE IS NOT ONE SINGLE MAYOR,
COUNTY JUDGE THAT I KNOW OF,
SHERIFF OR POLICE CHIEF OR OTHER
LAND OWNERS ARE SAYING
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
THEY ARE -- WE ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE FACING THIS ON GROUND 0 AND
WE JUST GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO SOMETHING ELSE BESIDES ACTING
LIKE THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
IT'S NOT CLOSED.
>> Sandra: AT WHAT POINT DO
THINGS HAVE TO START CHANGING
HERE?
I MEAN, WE HAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN
THIS ADMINISTRATION THAT ARE
ASSIGNED TO THE BORDER TO FIX
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE, AND
IT'S ONLY GETTING WORSE.
AT WHAT POINT DO PEOPLE HAVE TO
START LOSING THEIR JOBS?
>> WELL LOOK, WE HAVE A LOT OF
CAREER PEOPLE THAT KNOW WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE, THEY DO.
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THEIR WORK.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
DECISION.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
DECIDED ON THE FACTS, AND THE
FACTS ARE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE COMING IN, THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE WAITING ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE RIO GRANDE THAT ARE
WAITING FOR TITLE 42 TO GO AWAY,
AND YOU ARE GOING TO SEE NOT
THOUSANDS, YOU KNOW, SMALL
AMOUNT OF THOUSANDS, BUT YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT WILL BE
COMING OVER BECAUSE THEY ARE
WAITING.
THE CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE
PROMOTING THIS BECAUSE THE MORE
PEOPLE THAT COME -- GET ACROSS,
THE MORE MONEY THEY MAKE.
THEY MAKE MONEY OFF DRUGS AND
SMUGGLING AND TRAFFICKING PEOPLE
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
AND THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
MIGRANT, ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS
JUST GET TO THE TEXAS, OR THE
U.S. BORDER.
THEN AFTER THAT, TAXPAYERS
DOLLARS ARE USED TO GET THEM TO
THEIR POINT OF -- WHERE THEY
WANT TO END UP.
SO IT'S A GREAT DEAL.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS JUST PAY
FOR HALF THE TRIP AND THE OTHER
HALF OF THE TRIP WILL BE PAID BY
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS.
>> Sandra: SO CONGRESSMAN, YOU
HAVE PENNED THIS LETTER, A
PORTION OF IT READS THIS.
NEVER BEFORE IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY HAVE WE EXPERIENCED THIS
SCOPE AND SCALE OF ILLEGAL
BORDER CROSSINGS AND WE REMAIN
CONCERNED THAT YOUR
ADMINISTRATION, POINTING TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, HAS NOT
PROVIDED SUFFICIENT SUPPORT OR
RESOURCES TO DHS, TERMINATION OF
THE CDC TITLE 42 ORDER AT THIS
TIME WILL RESULT IN A COMPLETE
LOSS OF OPERATIONAL CONTROL OVER
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU DID NOT MINCE WORDS HERE,
SIR.
HAVE YOU HEARD ANYTHING BACK
FROM THIS WHITE HOUSE?
>> I HAVEN'T, I DON'T THINK
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN HAS, I DON'T
THINK SENATOR CORNYN, MY GOOD
FRIENDS TONY GONZALEZ HAS.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM THEM AND
AGAIN, TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS A WAY THAT YOU CAN
PROVIDE RESPECT AND DIGNITY TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING TO THE
BORDER BUT AT ONE TIME OR
ANOTHER YOU HAVE TO ENFORCE THE
LAW, AND IF ENFORCING THE LAW
MEANS DEPORTING SOME PEOPLE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE, OR CHANGING
THE RULES WHERE ASYLUM SEEKERS
CAN SEEK ASYLUM SOMEWHERE AND DO
IT IN AN ORDERLY WAY THROUGH THE
PORTS OF ENTRY INSTEAD OF IN
BETWEEN PORTS, THERE ARE THINGS
WE CAN DO.
SENDING MORE MONEY FOR
TECHNOLOGY, FOR EQUIPMENT, FOR
PERSONNEL, ALL OF THAT IS
IMPORTANT, I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT YOU GOT TO HAVE THE RIGHT
POLICIES IN PLACE.
>> Sandra: AND END WITH THIS
FINAL QUESTION, NOT SURE WHAT
YOUR ANSWER WAS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHY -- DO
THEY GET IT?
THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU SEE THE
DRUGS, TERRORISTS DISCOVERED IN
THE LINES FLOWING OVER THE
BORDER, YOU SEE AS YOU SAY
TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK ONCE ALL
THESE FOLKS GET HERE.
SO, WHY IS THE WHITE HOUSE DOING
NOTHING?
>> WELL, AGAIN, I'LL GIVE YOU
THE SAME ANSWER.
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S SOMETHING THEY NEED TO
ANSWER.
ALL I'M LOOKING AT, OR THE
REPERCUSSIONS FROM INACTION FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION.
I'M A DEMOCRAT.
I WANT TO BE CONSTRUCTIVE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I DON'T JUST GO AND VISIT THE
BORDER ONCE IN A WHILE, I LIVE
THERE, I TALK TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN THERE, AND WE -- AND THE
COMMUNITIES THERE.
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME CHANGES
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
>> Sandra: COME BACK ONCE YOU
HEAR SOMETHING FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WE HAVE SEEN YOUR LETTER, YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES